Before I can write the code, I need to figure out exactly what each of these
corners is, so that I can think about the end points of each of the lines I
need to draw are. This line's pretty easy, it goes from 20, 30 to 50, 10. This
one's a little bit trickier, this point is at the same height as that one, so
it's at 10. And it's 100 to the right from 50. That means that its x value is
matching up with this one, so that looks good. This point is 100 over from this
one. So, 100 plus 20. And this point, gives us 120, 30. And this point is 40,
down from this one. So 120, and 70. So we got that first line. Now the second
one. Is from 50, 10 to 150, 10. This line is 120, 30 to 150, 10. This line is
150, 10 to 150, 50. And this line. 120, 70 to 150, 50. The rectangle has its
top length here, and it gives us the width and the height. So we know how to
specify that one. Here's how I wrote the code to draw the crate. There's a
rectangle, which is that front face. Top left 20, 30, width 100, height 40.
Then there's that leftmost line. 20, 30 to match the point that it starts at
and 50,10 to match the point that it ends at. Then I did the same thing with
the top line, middle line, the rightmost line, and the bottom one. Then I had
to remember to draw each of these lines. And if I run this program, it draws
the three dimensional crate that I wanted. Good work if you got that. That was
a lot of getting all of the right coordinates in place. But if you did that,
you should be pretty familiar with drawing lines now.